what's going on guys the time has come
Deadpool the movie is hitting theaters
but not all of us are fully initiated
with Deadpool so we are bringing to you
please explain Deadpool and we have an
awesome panel of guests to tell us about
that first he's one of the hosts of
Marvel movie news he's also the producer
of Batman on Batman with Kevin Smith
welcome back to the show mat key and uh
he is an actor writer and he's also one
of the hosts of Marvel movie news I see
how that works huh coy Chandra let me
ask you guys
movie comes out tonight any special
plans oh I I actually have an awesome
fiance who very much wanted to see it on
Valentine's Day for our Valentine's Day
Wow nothing says love like Deadpool so
I've never had a chimichanga in my life
okay I've been waiting to have a
chimichanga until this movie came out of
it holding strong deadpool fans have
their own vernacular why do people love
Deadpool so much because the enthusiasts
are just it's an army I think there's no
one like him yeah he's a completely
different character there's no other
character that is aware that they're in
a comic book that breaks the fourth wall
that talks directly to the audience that
makes fun of the medium makes fun of
other heroes makes fun of the writers
who are writing I think he's the most
topical character for our generation I
think we live in a time of like Twitter
and Facebook and yes it's Rapide Rapide
everything is stimuli I want you to
educate us a little bit okay so if I am
the kind of uninitiated and I want to
learn a little Deadpool history I want
to bone up on some Deadpool before I see
the movie where would I begin best place
Joe Kelly's Ron Joe Kelly
I'd say the very beginning I'd read him
when he was actually like a commentary
on Deathstroke like when he was like up
cuz he started as a spoof Wow care so
that wasn't supposed to be the
successful this character shouldn't have
been a school but it was the 90s like
the night ends like so is that like a
slam on DC I mean it was not so subtle
yeah yeah I don't know that it was a
slam because Rob Liefeld invented him
because he liked Deathstroke so much it
was kind of a like a love letter to
bestrode okay so he puts him in New
Mutants 98 yeah the second appearance is
x-force number 2 right and that's a
cable and that's with cable so like
that's why I like Deadpool is
so tight into the x-force universe
uh-huh because that's kind of where he
started was in x-force so tell me a
little bit more about his origins he I
mean it changes a lot that's pretty yeah
he's been all over the place basically
he has debilitating cancer but has like
they activate his healing factor in some
continuities but that doesn't stop the
cancer just ravages his body and he
becomes basically a corpse that can't
die could you burn him to a crisp I
imagine like a dinner a subatomic level
he's been destroyed and come back like
you'd only been atomized and returned it
just took time like wow so there's no
real way to end Deadpool what are his
powers that changes - I mean that's
hands and you guys are slippery you're
not giving me enough solid answers like
his main power is his healing factor he
doesn't really have any other powers
beyond that he's got a teleportation
yeah it's something I'll Center like
teleport places he's an expert marksman
yeah he also like knows hand and combat
better than most and on stroke stuff but
the super strength comes and goes
sometimes they're like it's a sealing
factor makes him stronger like they just
don't quantify him at all talk to me
about his connection to the x-men he's a
fan like he's tried to become an x-men
so many times and they're like no no
he's sort of on par with the Punisher
where he's like you get the job done but
we it's you're also like a liability I
know uh some characters from the x-men
universe Colossus is in this film who
else talk to me about who we might
expect negasonic teenage warhead is the
other one uh-huh
and the comic books she was created by
Grant Morrison right like an x-men new
expendable new x-men run and I think she
was just like a telepath maybe she was a
telekinetic but she was all like only in
one book and in the comics who are loose
like Deadpool's crew who does he run
with most I mean cable is it like the
the go to like I like not buy cables you
know he's not happy about it gets the
job done they're a comedy team because
like cable is such a straight string
Kings Murtaugh it's and I know you have
these two polar assets that are trying
to yeah and yeah he's also he's got Bob
agent of Hydra who's a Hydra agent that
like tried to get away but basically
like he's his punching bag since he
knows he's a bad guy Deadpool feels like
an abused him and he hasn't as like a
henchman he's his Igor we should also
mention weasel we forgot to well the
mortals like Angela JJ Miller very much
a right-hand man like kind of a sidekick
yes some ways he's also like the tech
expert he's a weapons buyer he buys his
weapons he
with him a lot and who are his main
nemesis or enemies Ajax is kind of the
guy that caused him so like his big
nemesis I guess would be a jack to the
film yeah yeah Ajax has big powers that
he can't feel pain like he's super
strong uh like he's kind of like a
Captain America sort of character in
that way but he also just cannot feel
pain I once dated a woman who could not
feel emotion lady Barry's ha ha ha ha
fellas I don't want to bring up a sore
subject
not Deadpool's first motion picture
appearance talk to me about Wolverine
Origins and I mean do we have to happen
yes it was an enemy we must take of it I
feel like it was Reynolds trying to get
the characters awareness up so this
could eventually happen I feel like you
loved the character so much she was
willing to sacrifice like a little bit
of that to later on and then
unfortunately it was so bad that for a
while that killed it and they give him
like yeah Cyclops eyes it's just
shameful the Karaka arms why yeah it is
it has happened
do we like Ryan Reynolds as Deadpool I
think Ryan Reynolds was born Deadpool it
just took this long form to get the
costume cuz like even all the marketing
oak it's like like like half the viral
campaign has all been his idea
there wasn't any stink on Ryan Reynolds
from that previous incarnation of
Deadpool or Green Lantern were like no I
think it was Green Lantern that really
hurt him the most yeah um he's in a very
interesting career because he on paper
all his choices make sense and they
always come out you're like mmm does
this film need to be rated R absolutely
okay I don't think there's a version of
Deadpool that could exist you tell me
why because recently there was a kind of
a groundswell petition oh come on
put out a pg-13 version for us kids yeah
the trailer we already have it the only
positive to of being a pg-13 is that
that would be one more thing for him to
break the fourth wall on what do you say
to people who watch the trailers and say
oh the sophomoric why are there wiser
all that 90's hip hop in there what's
that I think that we need a sophomoric
character in that genre otherwise
everything becomes stagnant I think that
we need like ant-man Mo's our heist film
guardians their space opera our American
Pie superhero film the fanatical love
that you guys described I guess that's
why we have so much
Deadpool cosplay because look at those
Deadpool's and Harley Quinn's are
yeah go to it has the character that
like the trolls that want to be more out
there can where it's it's a mask you can
put on and be as obnoxious as you get be
a total goof yeah less you sort of like
transform your character and it gives
you sort of an excuse you know plus I
think like kids like when they first get
into comics I think Deadpool is a very
easy accessible character for them okay
let me throw a scenario you guys let's
say this movie's big hit Fox is like oh
we've got something huge on our hands
where do we want to see Deadpool next we
know that there's a new mutants movie
coming out so like find a way to slip
him into the new mutants movie right
would be like just perfect I think
padding Colossus and this allows us to
start planting seeds and then he can be
your through-line that Wolverine used to
be that's that's the one way I do it I'd
also like to have an x-force which is
like Marvel's answer to Suicide Squad so
I want x-force and I also think a soft
reboot by way of Deadpool you guys have
gotten me pretty king pumped yeah does
dead does Deadpool curse oh yeah
yes are you guys excited about Deadpool
let us know in the comments below and if
you see it tell us what you thought
Mackie toys and ro don't forget to watch
and listen to these guys on Marvel movie
news thank you for being here and
schooling us on all things dead cool I
want to thank you for watching I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye bye
the first matchup of the final for Fargo
versus oh brother where art thou
oh gosh why you making me choose between
my favorite because that's what we
signed up for here today god damn it